هل أنت فخور بما حدث هنا
اليوم بالتأكيد
أعتقد أنه كان يجب علينا المضي قدمًا
وانتزاع
أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ لدينا من شعر
الرأس وتخريبهم
، ولم يعد
هناك الآلاف
من القوات الموجودة
هنا في عاصمة الأمة.
تم تنشيط الحرس الوطني بأكمله من قبل
وزارة الدفاع الأمريكية
بعد هذا الغوغاء الذين هاجموا
مبنى الكابيتول الأمريكي.
أنت فخور بما حدث هنا
اليوم.
لقد سُرقت هذه الانتخابات ،
اضطررت إلى المجيء إلى هنا والقيام بواجبي الوطني.
هل أنت فخور بالمشاهد التي
جرت هنا اليوم أنا لست فخوراً
بها ،
فأنا أشعر بالتواضع بسببها ، وأنا
متحمس لذلك
لعام 1776 ولكننا  الحركة الشعبية
تتقدم.
إنه لأمر محزن أن يحدث ذلك.
فخورون بما حدث هنا
اليوم.
أنا فخور بأن الوطنيين خرجوا
اليوم لإظهار دعمهم
لرئيسنا لأنه دونا.  ترامب هو رئيسنا ،
أعني ولكن ما الذي
يحقق هذا العنف
لا يوجد عنف في العنف
هناك أشخاص تعرضوا للأذى منذ حوالي
عام
[موسيقى
] هل هذه حقًا طريقة
يجب أن يتصرف بها الرئيس
تمامًا ، نعم نعم حان الوقت لذلك  لقد قمت
بمسح المستنقع الذي ندفع
ثمنه لجعلهم يغشون
ويسرقون منا باستمرار ، هذا صحيح ،
لقد انتهينا من الأمر ،
نحن مسالمون ونعم ، لن يتم
إسكاتنا رغم
أن هذه طريقة مناسبة
للتصرف  بعد خسارة الانتخابات ،
يجب
علينا كوطنيين أمريكيين أن نفعل ما في وسعنا
لاستعادة هذا البلد